[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
friday september 2nd
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
prosecutors are calling it their first
case targeting insider trading in
non-fungible tokens
in june nathaniel chastain a former
employee of the nft marketplace open c
was accused of benefiting from knowledge
about whether the prices of some digital
art would go up
it's a novel case and one that could
test the bounds of fraud law in the u.s
but some lawyers say it could set a
dangerous precedent that goes beyond
digital assets joining us to discuss
this is richard vander ford from the
wsj's risk and compliance journal hi
richard thanks for being here thanks for
having me
so start with reminding us what happened
with nathaniel chastain
so nathaniel chastain was an employee of
openc which is a very large nft
marketplace he was a product manager
and one of his duties was to pick what
nfts for sale would be put on the front
of the website featured on the website
and so he obviously knew what was going
to go on the website and he's accused of
using that knowledge to buy up these
nfts before they went on the website
they would go on the website it would
drive interest and he would quickly sell
them to make big profits according to
prosecutors
and what has his legal team said about
these charges he's pleaded not guilty
his legal team isn't talking on the
record to reporters but they've asked
that the charges be dismissed
he's been charged under this wire fraud
statute and not under securities fraud
why is that important in this case
when most people think about insider
trading they think about insider trading
in stocks which is often charged under a
securities fraud statute wire fraud is a
really old law it's very broad it
encompasses all kinds of what people
would think of as crooked behavior and
prosecutors really like it because it's
very adaptable to new kinds of scams
so this case is really a test of whether
his conduct can be charged under this
wire fraud law that is very broad
what have opponents of this kind of case
said how do they feel about that kind of
approach
a group of prominent new york defense
attorneys have said that prosecutors are
going too far in using the wire fraud
statute this way and potentially
criminalizing a lot of normal workplace
conduct or minor misconduct that maybe
shouldn't be a crime
under the legal theory being used by
prosecutors here the crime is really in
taking the information from his employer
and using it to make money
so these defense lawyers have come up
with a bunch of scenarios that most
people wouldn't think of as criminal
like if companies headquarters were
moving
and an executive used that information
to buy a house before the market heated
up or if someone wrote a tell-all book
about their boss in defiance of a
non-disclosure agreement
these defense lawyers are saying under
the prosecutor's theory in this case
that kind of taking of confidential
workplace information could be a crime
but it probably shouldn't be
they've asked the judge to dismiss this
case do we know when we're going to kind
of get a reaction from the judge what we
expect to hear from him yeah so there'll
be a whole bunch of hearings on whether
to dismiss the case that kind of remedy
dismissing a case before goes to a jury
is really rare judges are really
inclined to give prosecutors the benefit
of the doubt and let their cases go
before a jury
that said there's appeals courts in new
york as well and the appeals court could
be more skeptical but i think it could
take months or years to fully unfold
what does the prosecution said about why
they're taking this tactic kind of going
wire fraud as opposed to securities
fraud they haven't outlined their their
legal theory or their sort of tactical
legal decision but
if you go under a wire fraud theory you
arguably don't have to prove that a
security was involved and there's a lot
of uncertainty about whether digital
assets like nfts or cryptocurrency can
be considered a security a lot of
differences of legal opinion about that
so under this theory the crime is just
that he allegedly took
information from his workplace and used
that to profit and you don't have to get
into a question of well is this a
security or is this not a security
i wonder though you know this group of
defense attorneys is saying it could set
a precedent for workplace misconduct
could it set a precedent for kind of how
we think about digital assets and how
crimes around digital assets are
prosecuted yeah a win for the
prosecutors here would be huge it's the
manhattan federal prosecutors who
brought this case and they typically are
very aggressive and obviously there's a
lot of kind of digital asset work being
centered in manhattan and in new york so
if the prosecutors win
and an appeals court agrees with them
especially then
this theory would be vindicated and
assets that people might not have
thought of as being an insider tradable
asset will de facto be something you
could insider trade and violate the law
in that way
you know nfts were so popular last year
they were surging in value now that's
not the case anymore will that in any
way impact this trial
i don't think prosecutors are going to
walk away from a case like this because
like nfts turn out to be sort of an
irrelevant thing i think once they start
on a case they want to win
and i think the prosecutors in manhattan
they want to be seen policing these
digital assets they made a show of
saying this is the first ever nft
insider trading case they brought a case
the month after this in cryptocurrency
insider trading and the relative
popularity of nfts isn't going to really
change the way the trial goes
all right that's our reporter richard
vander ford thanks so much for joining
us richard thank you
and that's it for tech news briefing
this week our producer is julie chang
our supervising producer is chris
sinsley our executive producer is kateri
yocum and i'm your host zoe thomas
before we go a quick programming note
we'll be off this coming monday for
labor day but we'll be back on tuesday
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
[Music]
you